So who's my guest this week?
The last Afghan Women's
Minister, Hasina Safi.
Afghanistan, the 1970s,
an era of hope for women.
As the '80s started, my guest turned 5,
and everything changed.
Over time, freedoms and
education were rolled back,
violence and humiliation commonplace.
She and her family escaped,
and as the years passed,
she dedicated herself in exile
to campaigning for women's rights.
As democracy returned to
Afghanistan, so did she,
eventually appointed to run
the Ministry of Women's Affairs
under the last Afghan government,
only to have to escape again last August,
as the Taliban regained power.
Ever since, she's been
living with her family
as a refugee, in a London hotel.
This interview is going to give you
a remarkably powerful account
of what it was like to flee the Taliban.
Here's what's coming up.
I had nothing to feel.
I was not even concerned
about what will happen to me,
I was so concerned with the
big, big, big group of people
that I was seeing there.
What have we done that
we are facing this time?
So it's very different.
I really forgot that I am living.
When I was eating, I was crying,
because I thought that, "I'm eating,
but there are many people
who are not eating there.
Why should I eat?
Why should I live?
I couldn't help any women back there.
Hasina, thank you so much for joining us.
Welcome to the program.
Thank you very much for the opportunity.
I wanted to start by saying,
do you worry that the
world has forgotten a bit
about Afghanistan, at the moment?
What I see today is
there is a very total uncertainty globally
about what to do,
whereas the world has forgotten
that there was a 20 years of investment
on the human resources of Afghanistan,
so there is always a hope and
an approach to move forward.
They have forgotten, but
there are many opportunities
if they just dig out about
or within their surroundings.
How are the people that you're talking to,
as you say, left alone under the Taliban?
I think, basically, there
is still a lot of fear,
there is a lot of uncertainty,
there is a lot of hopelessness,
and also insecurity.
So the people really do not know,
because almost every
week, there is a new news,
and instead of the
situation getting better,
or the situation becoming hopeful,
it's becoming deteriorating,
starting from the day one,
where stopping women for going to offices,
abolishment of Women Ministry,
the same thing, stopping
of women organizations,
and asking the women who
were in leadership positions,
those who were still in Afghanistan,
to stay back home,
and many other things.
So day by day, there is
not a concrete or tangible
indicator or directive
through which you can see
that there is a space or a place
for the women of Afghanistan,
or for their future.
But also, if I may say, with these reports
of girls getting ready
to go back into school,
so excited, really looking forward
to being able to go back in,
the boys have been let back
in, the girls have not,
but on the actual day they
were expected to go in,
there is a U-turn, they
they don't let them in.
Everyone is shocked. Why?
Is it a sin to be a girl
in a certain location?
No, it's not. So what is it?
It's a country, it's a structure.
There are many, many big
things to think about.
Why is a women's scarf, a
women's dress, a women's school,
why is this an agenda?
There are many national
priorities to move forward
for nation building, for the
development of the country.
Why is this the first priority
at this critical situation?
And why do you think it is,
knowing what you know of the Taliban,
having lived through the
time that you've been in?
I think there is no clear vision,
there is no clear structure,
there is no governance policy.
There has been a big investment
on the education of women,
generally, education,
and then specifically, on women and girls
in the last 20 years,
so for me, not only the
present de facto government
but also the international community
shall be accountable,
because they have invested so much
in education and health.
Why are they just becoming
only the people who are listening?
Why there is no intervention?
Where is the mutual accountability?
Why are we not talking?
We are all related to each
other as the basis of humanity,
as the basis of investment
in the last 20 years.
Do you think that women
will get an education,
that women will be allowed
back into their jobs?
What are your levels of
hope like at the moment?
Well, presently, from
the situation that I see
about the present
structure in Afghanistan,
I'm totally hopeless,
because day after day, you hear things
that you can't even imagine.
Why would the girls not go to school,
even if there is no resources?
Where are the commitments? Why-
For example we heard
that the teachers and the
doctors are getting their pay,
so why are they getting the pay
if the children are not going to school?
So there should be a
very clear definition,
a very clear structure
of what they want to do.
So that is why it is really hopeless
in present situation in Afghanistan.
But on the whole, the world
is there to help each other.
This is the time for the world
to think about the people of Afghanistan,
to think about the women of Afghanistan.
To take your mind back, if I may,
to what happened in August.
I mean, much has been made
about how chaotic the evacuation was.
I think there was not a proper plan.
There was not a proper plan
for the way it was proceeded.
The decision was taken,
plans could be done,
plans could be made,
discussions could be made
on an ad hoc, urgent basis,
but they did not happen.
That is why today, still,
there are many, many people
who need to be evacuated,
they are stuck, they
are back in Afghanistan,
whose lives are real in danger.
Because they helped the West
That is-
and now they're on a list
with the Taliban, or-
Because they helped the West
but they helped the humanity.
Yes.
They wanted to live generally,
But I mean, that's how
like-
they would be viewed
by the Taliban, potentially.
That's why you say
Exactly.
they would be in danger
So they are still stuck in Afghanistan.
That is why, whenever I'm talking,
I'm basically suggesting for the world
on three basic or fundamental issues.
The first one is urgent
action on humanitarian
and protection of those people
who really invested their lives forward
for the success of the
international donation,
or help, or support.
The second thing is the midterm
solution for me, as a woman.
The caretaker has no vision
for women, as a woman,
and we can never ignore women,
especially in a country like Afghanistan,
where the majority of
population are women.
And the third thing is the definition
of the international
relation with Afghanistan.
The international community
should really sit together
and based on their priorities,
they have to match up the
present situation of Afghanistan
for a reason, which is help and support
the humanity, the people, and the women
of Afghanistan.
Beyond financial aid.
Exactly.
you're talking about,
because, of course, that has been the way
that Afghanistan has just
about avoided famine,
because of the levels of donation,
food, aid, on that front,
but you're talking about
actually intervening.
Exactly.
How did you actually escape?
Emma, to be honest, I
was not planning to leave
Really?
Yes.
My plan was that I cannot leave
because there are so many
women who need me here.
But after that, I saw that the
situation was deteriorating,
and some of my close friends suggested
that, "Your life is valuable for us."
I had worked a lot with
the British organizations
in Foreign Ministry,
and I really don't know
how I wrote the email.
I did not know who to contact,
but I wrote the email in
the contacts which I had,
and then, I think, after two days,
and definitely coordination
of the international sisters
who had made an informal group
to save the lives of women,
especially the women who were
in decision-making positions,
they were in constant contact.
They were telling me,
"You will get an email,
you will get an email."
And almost every second, they would say,
"Did you get an email?
Did you get a email?"
And then after, when I
received the email from them
that, "You have to come to
Baron Hotel in 12 hours."
I did not know where Baron Hotel was.
That's in Afghanistan? Yes.
Yes, yes.
I did not have any vehicle,
so I messaged them back,
not the email address,
but the group of women
who were helping me,
I told them, "I have no
vehicles, nothing to go,
so can you arrange for the vehicles?"
They told me, "We will try."
So they arranged once,
and then I think there
were some security issues,
they canceled it.
Because, like, I never was
assuming this situation,
so that is why.
And I was a role model to many people
because I also believe in a balanced life,
so I was a lot in
public, everyone knew me,
shopkeepers, everyone knew me there.
That is why there was a
lot of security issues
on those days.
One of the other female
minister, former minister,
she called me and she gave me
the number who had helped her,
and they were demanding for
some financial, like, rent,
so I got my son's piggy bank,
where we were, all the
time, in his birthday,
we were giving him,
and we broke that, and we had some money
which we could give the logistic company,
or the people who-
We did not go through the formal airport
because it was too crowded.
Someone told us that
you can go from behind,
the drivers, they guided us.
We went there. The family was with me.
They told me to go in,
but when I went there, it
was a terrible situation.
There was a lot of fire guns,
there was a lot of lashing,
they were lashing people.
Some of the family got lashes.
The Taliban were doing this?
Yes, yes, yes.
And some of your family
Yes.
Three of the family members
received lashes?
received lashes.
And then I decided that, no way,
because they were also gun firing,
and I said if something
happens to them and I'm alive,
I will never live with that guilt.
So we decided, me and my husband,
that we will go back home,
whatever happened on the way.
I was on half of the way
when my friend, the former minister,
she called me, and she
scolded me, in fact.
She said, "Don't do this mistake.
You have to come."
There is a canal
where the suicide attack
happened two days after,
so she said, "We also came from that way."
I said I cannot go because
my family is with me
and I had a elderly, sick mother.
She said, "No, whatever
you do, if you go back,
I know you will not be alive."
And then, when I went
there, there was a big crowd
going up, going down, going up.
I think maybe 1,000 or
800 people were there.
So we came up.
Finally, we came, and I called a number.
I don't know, it's maybe
destiny, or God helped us,
the number went through,
and it was one of my female friends
who were organizing this,
and I called her, and I said,
"I don't know what to do.
I'm in here, in the crowd.
I'm on the top of that
dirty ditch with the family.
What to do?"
So you're standing with
all of your family,
there's a lot of people around.
Almost-
I'm just trying
to picture this.
Yes.
And you're at the top
of a ditch, you said,
Yes, yes, there is-
and you're ringing someone
to try and find out
Yes, yes.
how you can leave Afghanistan,
how you can escape.
Yes, yes.
How are you feeling at this time,
that you've got elderly family with you,
you've got your children, and you-
That's why, Emma, I told you
that I really did not understand
what was all the struggle that
I did in the last 20 years?
It was the second time that
I had to leave my country.
I left my country when I was 5 years old,
when Russia invaded Afghanistan,
and from 5 years old till 25,
I struggled with each drop of my blood
to go back, invest my
knowledge, invest my talent,
for my coming generations,
so that they do not feel.
And I really was killed
on that night, Emma.
I had nothing to feel.
I had no feelings.
My only concern,
I was not even concerned
about what will happen to me,
I was so concerned with the
big, big, big group of people
that I was seeing there.
People were sitting with their papers,
passports, everything,
and they were saying, "Oh,
I have worked with this.
Oh, I have..."
And I was like, "How helpless we are.
What have we done that
we are facing this time?"
So that is why it was really, like,
to be very honest, I could not
feel anything till one month.
I was all the time crying.
In the middle of the night, I
was sweating, I was waking up,
and I was thinking someone
is knocking the door,
or there is something happening outside.
There are some of their own voices,
or whatever they were doing.
So it's very different, very different.
I really forgot that I am living.
When I was eating, I was crying,
because I thought that, "I'm eating,
but there are many people
who are not eating there.
Why should I eat?
Why should I live?
I couldn't help any women back there.
I'm so sorry.
Still it's like that.
It's difficult. It's very difficult.
I think even just that
moment that you described,
where you have to be with your family
and you've got to think
about them and being safe,
but you have such a duty to
your people and to your country.
Even then, I tried to
help, but I was helpless.
I couldn't help myself,
I couldn't help anyone.
So it's very difficult.
And then after that,
the soldier told us, "You are safe now,"
and then they took us inside the airport,
because we left that place,
so he did not know where to take us,
so I showed the paper, and then he took us
to that ground where the
planes were departing.
They were sitting and departing.
I think maybe for three or
five hours, we were there.
There were the big space
planes, they were leaving.
All of a sudden, I saw that
it was written 'Royal Space'
and I told the soldier that,
"Can you show this paper
to that commander?"
He said, "I'm not allowed to."
I said, "Okay, if you're not allowed,
I will stay here, no problem."
I have been constantly asking him
about how long should we stay?
He said, "We don't know."
And then I think it was around
one o'clock, at 1:00 a.m.,
that the soldier went, but he came back.
He said, "I will take the paper."
So he took the paper to the UK soldier,
commander, I think,
then he took the paper, he read that,
and he took that to inside the plane.
Maybe there or somewhere,
and then they waved to us,
and after that, we entered the bus,
and they said that, "You
are in safe hands now."
And we were all crying Emma on that time.
We even didn't know
how to hug each other.
So it was a difficult time.
And then after that,
we came to the UK base,
and from that onwards,
I think, as a human being,
I have to recognize that,
that it was all care and
humanity for everyone.
There was no special, there
was no prioritization,
but they were just treating everyone.
I know how hard and difficult
it must be for them.
They have been in
constant work as a person.
You're still with your
family, as I understand it,
in a hotel,
Yes.
In the UK.
And it's about seven months or so now
that you will have been
in this accommodation.
How has that been?
You know, we're thinking a lot
about how many people are
displaced at the moment
around the world.
This is the second time
that you've done this,
but how has it been
for your family and you
living in the hotel?
Actually, to be very honest, Emma,
they were very concerned about my life,
so none of them have
been telling me anything,
but from what I see, they
are hiding their feelings
because of me, because they know
that I'm very, very concerned
about the people back there.
When you say that, you mean your family?
Yes. I know it's difficult for them.
It's very difficult,
because a home is a home,
and a hotel is a hotel.
We are getting everything.
There is food, there is
rooms, there is internet.
But definitely, if it's home,
all the time, we say it's home sweet home,
so home is always sweet,
but they haven't been
saying anything about that,
because whenever they-
How I understand that they are concerned
is whenever they say this, they say,
"Oh, we are blessed that you are alive."
So that is what, on that time,
I analyze that they must be missing home,
they must be missing their home,
they must be missing home here.
Do you think you can
build a life in the UK?
Of course I can, because
I believe in humanity,
and the reason that today I'm here
is basically the human belief that I have,
and that is why I again
stress on humanity,
on connection, on relation, on confidence,
because it's nothing else
but the high value of those friends
who really believed and
worked with me as a human.
I did not ask them, really.
They asked me at the beginning,
"Hasina, how are you?
Hasina, are you fine?
Hasina, are you okay?
Hasina, good morning. How are you?
Did you eat? Did you-"
So there is no policy or anything in here.
It's just a real connection of humanity.
I'm very confident that I can do that.
Do you think you'll ever
be able to go back again
and live in Afghanistan?
Yes.
You do?
Yes, because I'm a very hopeful person.
I'm a very positive person.
I will have challenges,
we will have challenges,
but I know that struggle brings result,
and I will struggle to bring
the result, so that is why.
I am hopeful, but I need to
struggle double and triple
to really get to those who need me.
Hasina Safi, thank you so
much for talking to me.
Thank you very much.
And thank you to you for being with us,
and listening to that
remarkable conversation.
Until we meet again, do
take care, and goodbye.